[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Jean-Daniel Laval
directeur du Théâtre de
Fontenay-le-Fleury bonjour bonjour alors
votre salle de spectacle est donc situé
à Fontenay-le-Fleury vous y proposez
tout au long de l'année des pièces de
théâtre et des spectacles jordaniel
Laval vous êtes vous-même metteur en
scène alors selon vous que permet le
théâtre au quotidien en tout cas que
cherchez-vous à travers vos mises en
scène et votre programmation ah mais ça
c'est une question pour deux heures
d'interview alors parce que c'est très
complexe non ce qu'on cherche toujours
dans le cadre d'une commune de 14000
habitants comme fontaine fleurie c'est
plutôt le bien vivre ensemble la
communauté l'échange c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est envahi par
beaucoup d'informations de tout genre et
je trouve que un peu de poésie un peu de
dard de de burlesque même aussi c'est
pas interdit mais de création surtout
d'imaginaire de rêveries je pense que
c'est pas inutile c'est un
c'est un denrée qui qui n'est pas si
cher finalement quand on y pense moins
que le gaz ça permet de s'évader
finalement oui s'évader alors c'est pas
non plus penser que s'évader c'est une
manière de fuir non s'évader c'est
s'évader on réfléchissant quand même
c'est à dire que à prendre du recul sur
les choses je crois que c'est ça qui est
important c'est qu'on est noyé à
l'intérieur quelque chose en pensant que
c'est la fin du monde alors que si on
prend un peu de recul on s'aperçoit que
finalement tout ça il y a beaucoup de
dérisions beaucoup d'absurde car votre
salle de spectacle est en travaux depuis
plusieurs mois la réouverture est prévue
pour juillet 2023 pour autant vous
continuez à programmer des spectacles
mais cette fois hors les murs alors
pourquoi continuer à programmer
justement des spectacles sur le
territoire de Fontenay-le-Fleury et bien
alors la cette deuxième question accorde
avec la première toujours pour garder le
contact avec ce public et avoir ce désir
de
de faire exister cette cette passion qui
nous semble importante et essentielle
donc c'est vrai qu'on fait hors les murs
d'abord parce que ça on trouve ça
original ça nous permet ça permet aux
fantaisies aussi de redécouvrir un peu
leur vie la chapelle l'église le bon on
a fait dans une ferme on a fait
à comment dirais la mairie même la salle
des mariages c'était assez rigolo on a
fait un superbe spectacle s'appelait je
vous aime que chose un peu chorale comme
ça bref on aime bien ça c'est voilà de
toute façon je crois que même sur mon
lit d'hôpital je continuerai à faire un
spectacle pour les infirmières qui sont
là donc et pourquoi c'est choix de de
lieux justement est-ce que est-ce qu'il
y a une sorte de d'association entre
entre vous et les lieux ouais absolument
c'est à dire que c'est ou ou ou un
spectacle nous semble cohérent on veut
le montrer le présenter et alors on va
chercher le lieu en adéquation avec ou
alors tiens on se dit ce lieu et
crédible est possible pourquoi on
essaierait pas de trouver un spectacle
qui va dedans dans les deux sens ça
marche donc la chap par exemple qui est
un lieu un peu intimiste assez assez
joli quand un charme on y a mis du
Pagnol par exemple ça suffit très bien
le son des cigales était très
intéressant ou alors faire du Beckett
dans une bibliothèque ça nous a paru
logique et je vais faire le sermon sur
la sur le mode du mauvais riche de
Bossuet à l'église et là ça me paraît
logique aussi et pour autant on imagine
que vous êtes pressé de rouvrir les les
portes du théâtre de Fontenay-le-Fleury
quels sont les travaux effectués
justement dans dans cette salle de de
spectacle qu'est-ce que ça va apporter
aux comédiens et au spectateur alors
d'énormes choses alors après on peut
rentrer dans des détails style les
marches seront un peu plus accessibles
parce qu'elles étaient un peu hautes et
les personnes âgées avaient des
difficultés à rentrer dans la salle la
régie est maintenant en dur et donc
mieux installé donc pour les techniciens
c'est préférable tout a été amélioré au
niveau scénique c'est-à-dire tout ce
qu'on appelle tout ce qui soutient les
projecteurs et tout ça maintenant a été
électrique et non plus à la main enfin
bref il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont
évolué pour le confort du travail mais
alors pour le confort du spectateur
attendez quand même deux éléments
fondamentaux qui sont notamment le
système Atmos qu'on va avoir pour le
cinéma et ça je crois qu'on doit être un
peu pas loin d'être les seuls dans la
région à la voir parce que c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est à dire cette
espèce d'immersion sonore
dans les films sont pourvus aujourd'hui
dans une salle quand même qui fait 350
places avec un écran qui fera 12 m de
d'ouverture c'est pas mal donc très très
belle salle de cinéma donc j'encourage
les gens à s'y intéresser dès que ça
rouvre et puis une autre chose aussi
c'est qu'on a été aidé par le
Département financé en partie pour la
captation c'est à dire vraiment un
matériel de rigide de captation qui va
nous permettre de faire des des des
prises d'image et de son en diffusé en
direct pour les publics empêchés comme
la maison de retraite de tel endroit
comme nous on a les sources qui est à
une maison médicalisée pour les
schizophrèves des choses comme ça ça on
a trouvé ça très intéressant de pouvoir
s'équiper de cette chose là et de
pouvoir offrir
c'est le covid qui nous a
produit cette imaginaire parce que c'est
vrai que on s'est aperçu que le vivant
et le était formidable la présence dans
la salle est indispensable mais quand on
peut pas y aller on peut pas y aller
donc c'est dommage de priver les gens
des spectacles et il y a beaucoup de
compagnies qui acceptent volontiers de
diffuser de façon privée d'une certaine
façon justement on va revenir aussi sur
sur ces spectacles hors les murs comment
on pris cette cette nouvelle les
compagnies est-ce qu'elles ont
rapidement accepté finalement d'avoir
aussi un lieu qui se rapprocher parfois
un peu plus de de leur spectacle ouais
mais très très bien d'avoir ils ont pas
été pris en train de la proposition mais
par exemple la compagnie
montre un peu pour voir je crois ça
s'appelle je vous aime qui s'est fait à
la salle des mariages on avait même
prévu de de de les accueillir
confortablement avec de la lumière non
non on sait très bien comme ça on touche
à rien ce formidable c'est vrai que le
côté brut de pomme comme ça de
l'installation d'un spectacle je trouve
que ça confère une certaine exigence et
rigueur au spectacle et puis ça leur
offre aussi une un crédit quant à la
quant à la pertinence il y a plus de
superficielles tout d'un coup on est
vraiment dans le creuser le Pagnol dans
la chapelle où il avait évidemment pas
tout son confort qu'il a actuellement il
joue à l'essaillons par exemple
peut-être essayons tous les tous les
mardis je crois il a pas ce confort là
et en fait il a beaucoup apprécié parce
qu'il y avait ce côté un peu insolite et
ça contraint l'acteur l'artiste allait à
l'essentiel ça moi je suis à ses clients
de ça et vous vous l'avez évoqué un
14000 habitants à Fontenay-le-Fleury des
travaux avec notamment donc une
captation la salle de cinéma aussi avec
une expérience une expérience auditive
un petit peu inédite on va dire est-ce
que justement votre votre objectif c'est
de pérenniser la place de la culture sur
le territoire de Fontenay-le-Fleury ah
mais carrément
carrément
en plus je trouve que Fontenay-le-Fleury
et la municipalité qui nous soutient
faut le dire humblement c'est pas sans
en faire de la publicité
non plus des excès
a compris le processus d'un
schéma culturel local c'est à dire qu'on
est vraiment un planter il y a quatre
écoles primaires qu'on fait énormément
travailler en action culturelle il y a
des centres aérés il y a voilà c'est à
dire qu'on travaille à l'échelle de vous
savez 14000 habitants ça ça fait vivre
un théâtre de cette dimension là sans
problème et je trouve que chaque commune
devrait s'équiper de façon pertinente et
intelligente de ce genre de d'outils
c'est des outils indispensables je
voyais qu'il y avait une pétition qui
était lancée contre le département qui
s'intéressait plus au sport ou est-ce
que studio parce que le sport pourquoi
pas ça existe aussi enfin mais je trouve
peut-être cette pétition peut-être est
injuste mais néanmoins ils ont raison en
tout cas de signaler de d'alerter en
dire faites attention ne perdez pas ce
ce qui a été acquis dans le territoire
c'est fondamental ça me paraît
fondamental alors vous avez également
des projets pour pour 2023 le premier
c'est un parcours de théâtre en jardin
au mois de au mois de mars alors
dites-nous-en un peu plus sur cette sur
cet événement oui parce que c'est dans
le cadre de la Journée de la poésie je
crois ça doit exister un truc comme ça
dans la période de c'est
pas du tout quelque chose que j'ai
imaginé
ça existe il y a beaucoup de choses
autour des jardins autour des
vide-greniers des choses comme ça donc
c'est les Fantasia qui ouvre leur jardin
il y en aura 8 parce que ça suit le ça
suit la poésie de Victor Hugo qui
s'appelle Les Contemplations autour du
texte de Léopoldine et donc chaque
extrait sera lu dans les jardins et ça
permet aux gens d'abord de visiter
jardins d'avoir un moment apaisé
agréable au printemps et puis avec un
petit rallye c'est-à-dire comme les les
les les trucs les questions les quiz ça
intéresse les gens aujourd'hui c'est un
peu la mode donc il y aura un petit quiz
sympathique pour finir avec un panier
garni pourquoi pas ça finalement on peut
dire que vous vous réinventez à travers
à travers ces événements oui oui
réinvente et d'ailleurs je serai très
honnête avec vous en vous disant que
c'est la partie la plus plaisante pour
nous c'est le challenge c'est toujours
plus intéressant que mais bon le théâtre
on aime ça je vous rassure et au mois de
au mois de mai alors c'est du 12 au 14
mai pour être plus précis il y a le
Beethoven project alors qu'est-ce que
c'est alors ça c'est un quatuor de de
copains et qui d'ailleurs font aussi du
burlesque avec leur avec leurs quatre
instruments un peu comme le traditionnel
quatuor qu'on a connu à l'époque et là
ils avaient un rêve ça s'est fait autour
de d'une table avec du thé bien sûr nous
sommes d'accord et où ils me disent
écoute on a un rêve c'est de jouer les
8h30 de l'oeuvre de Beethoven écrite
pour les quatuors s'il y en a 8h30 et
donc j'ai dit d'accord on parle
là-dessus et donc sur un week-end ils
vont jouer dans tous les endroits de la
ville ça peut être au parc public ça
peut être au marché ça peut aider
pendant 8h pendant 8h30 ils vont faire
les 8h30 par couper par opus puisqu'il y
a des opus de 45 minutes des opus de 20
minutes ça il y aura des parties fermées
payantes et des parties ouvertes
gratuites pour donné envie aux gens de
continuer le parcours avec de Beethoven
mais on aura le temps de l'ajouter sur
l'agenda parce que c'est du 12 au 14 mai
2023 merci beaucoup Jean-Daniel Laval
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation donc
pour plus d'informations sur la
programmation notamment on peut se
rendre sur le site théâtre de
fontenay.fr et pour voir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]